So if we start by looking at a varying number of elements per row,
what we've just seen is that the thread per element approach
is insensitive to the structure of the matrix,
whereas if we have a varying number of elements per row,
thread per row suffers from load imbalance
and it has a runtime dependent on the longest row.
So of these 2 methods, thread per element is probably a better choice.
It's completely insensitive to the structure of the matrix.
But on the other hand, if our matrices have roughly the same number of elements in each row,
which is better?
Well, now there's really no load imbalance issues,
and that's the primary disadvantage with the thread per row approach.
And in this case, where we have a similar number of elements per row,
it turns out that thread per row is roughly 3 times faster than thread per element. How come?
Well, in thread per row, all of the partial products are accumulated within a single thread,
so they're going to communicate through registers
and there's no communication between threads at all.
In thread per element, on the other hand,
the segmented scan operation requires communicating between threads
to sum up the partial products. That communication is more expensive.
So, because we have different performance characteristics here,
it's kind of a head-scratcher problem.
Which data structure do we choose,
given that we probably don't know what the structure of the matrix is
before we need to make this call?